[Musica]
stavo affrontando la situazione
veramente difficile quattro anni fa
Avete presente quasi prova Quando si
inizia una nuova esperienza
quando per esempio ti trasferisci in una
nuova città in una nuova squadra di
calcio o in una nuova scuola
mi riferisco proprio a quelle situazioni
in cui ti ritrovi in un oceano di
emozioni contrastanti
gli passi dall'essere euforico sereno
contento
all'essere confuso
impaurito
solo
quando infatti nel 2018 ho deciso di
trasferirmi in Lombardia per studiare
ingegneria presso l'Università di zona
ero da poco maggiorenne ma forte del
supporto dei miei amici della mia
famiglia e in particolar modo dei miei
genitori che non smetterò mai di
ringraziare
Scusatemi stamattina
[Applauso]
ero sicuro che l'avrei affrontato
serenamente ma come potete vedere di
parlare di questo argomento
mi fa tornare in mente determinate cose
e infatti la mia prima grande esperienza
fuori casa è iniziata proprio come ve
l'ho raccontata poc'anzi
in un oceano di emozioni contrastanti
tre Foria
e paura
in cui la mancanza di casa è la
solitudine si facevano sentire spesso
solitudine come per tanti studenti
All'inizio di una nuova esperienza
accademica Perché sì
spesso gli studenti sono soli
e lo posso dire perché Credetemi
conosco questa sensazione veramente bene
ma sicuramente ero più piccolo avevo a
malapena 18 anni sono sicuro che farlo
adesso a 23 sarebbe una cosa
completamente diversa
Ed è proprio così con questo pensiero
fisso nella mia testa con questa
credenza forte che a febbraio di
quest'anno del 2022 ho deciso di andare
a fare un'esperienza in Olanda Boom
di nuovo
stesse sensazioni
Forse però come ben possiamo immaginare
la mia non è l'unica storia
Infatti purtroppo solamente in Italia
quasi il 44% degli studenti soffre di un
forte senso di squilibrio Tra studio e
socializzazione
è spaventoso
sapere che quasi 960 mila studenti
soffre di problemi legati alla salute
mentale
perché
perché Nell'era della digitalizzazione e
delle interconnessioni globali
i ragazzi che soffrono di solitudine
sono in costante aumento
sembra quasi un paradosso no
tutte più connesse e soggetto a
interdipendenza
Ma ragazzi si sentono sempre più soli
tanti nella stanza dal pubblico agli
speaker fanno parte della generazione Z
una generazione che come la definisce
una famosa rivista americana e dinamica
ed impaziente che necessita di tutto
subito e con una certa qualità
e noi dobbiamo essere consapevoli che
nessuno
più di questa generazione abbia
l'esigenza di essere unita
di essere consapevole e di essere
supportata in un mondo in cui
l'imprevedibilità faccia da padrone
quindi
se la generazione di cui facciamo parte
è questa la prima ad essere immersa nel
digitale dalla nascita Ma che si sente
sempre più sola rispetto a quelle del
passato quando il digitale non esisteva
viene naturale arriverà da almeno due
considerazioni
la prima
il digitale danneggia
classica espressione anni 2000 un po'
troppo miope e stereotipato sostenere
singolarmente
non esiste una soluzione efficace
conosciuta è ben distribuita che aiuti
gli studenti in difficoltà psicologica
non esiste una soluzione efficace
conosciuta
è ben distribuita che aiuti gli studenti
in difficoltà psicologica
forse ci stiamo avvicinando ma proviamo
assieme a percorrere questa direzione
Quindi abbiamo detto generazione e
dinamica impaziente
tecnologie digitali
Ma perché non provare ad attenuare un
problema così grande
sfruttando quello che la generazione
digitale sa fare meglio
connettersi
la mia infanzia in un piccolo paesino
nel su Sardegna chiamato Sant'Antioco mi
insegna che è un problema così grande
possa diventare piccolo con la
cooperazione di persone che stiano
vivendo o abbiano vissuta almeno una
volta nella vita la nostra stessa
situazione
e immaginiamoci adesso di poterci
collegare quando e come vogliamo una
community come questa
ma per farvi capire meglio Lasciatemi
portare un esempio concreto No adesso
tutti immaginiamoci di essere ad agosto
ok È tra un mese dobbiamo salire
sull'aereo che ci porterà verso la
nostra nuova città presso la nostra
università
e indovinate un po' in che situazione ci
troviamo
in un oceano di emozioni contrastanti sì
e paura
però
un sollievo imitatoci a Sale quando
scopriamo che con un click sul nostro
cellulare
un ecosistema digitale ci semplifica
Decisamente la vita da matricole
universitaria
E questo perché ci dà la possibilità di
conoscere immediatamente gli studenti
universitari della nostra nuova città
ci dà la possibilità di essere
costantemente aggiornati sulle news
universitarie sul gossip studentesco
sappiamo dove andare a bere una birra
economica insieme ai nostri nuovi amici
per conoscere ulteriori compagni di
corso e ultimo non per importanza
sappiamo di poter contare su una
community di persone proprio come noi
Sì insomma sappiamo di non essere gli
unici di non essere sbagliati
ma di poter essere supportati dalla
Community come questa
questo può fare la differenza può fare
differenza avere la possibilità di
confrontarsi con quelle persone che
stanno vivendo o hanno vissuto almeno
una volta nella vita magari proprio in
quel momento come noi le nostre stesse
situazioni le nostre stesse ansie
per poterci confrontare con loro per
poter trovare una spalla concreta grazie
a cui distrarsi e grazie a cui
velocizzare il processo di integrazione
nelle università
questo
unito ai professionisti e alle aziende
esistenti può essere la differenza può
essere la chiave vincente
Personalmente io sostengo con forza la
scelta di volersi esporre a delle
esperienze come queste Sfidanti perché
credo che siano quelle che dal profondo
forgino le persone e di conseguenza sono
molto sensibili al tema
dell'integrazione dei fuori sede e del
collegamento tra studenti
per la creazione di un ambiente sereno
un ambiente dall'altra produttività
e per avere come conseguenza un futuro
migliore
a partire da oggi però
perché oggi su questa barca ci siamo noi
la generazione digitale Ed è proprio da
dentro questa barca che da giovane
imprenditore insieme ad altri giovani
imprenditori sto lavorando duramente per
rendere concreta questa visione
una visione che può essere la chiave per
un cambiamento radicale
Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]